florian from neuro 9 has a popular
software youtube channel and in this
course he will teach you how to use the
vim code editor what is going on guys
welcome to this vim course on free code
camp in today's video i want to guide
you through a full vim course from
beginning to end step by step and i want
to start out with some basic motivation
talking about why to use vim what vim
actually is and also showing you a
preview of what vim can look like if you
have some plugins installed and all that
and i want to do so because i think for
a lot of people out there vim is this
boring featureless text editor that you
have in the linux command line if you
don't have any alternatives on a server
for example you use vim otherwise you
don't use vim and a lot of people don't
even know how to exit them and all that
so we're going to talk about all this
why you should use them why learning
them can be important and interesting
and then we're going to move on to the
installation to finding the installation
that you already have to installing uh
vim on windows for example if you don't
have it installed natively we're going
to talk about that and then we're going
to get into some basic key bindings
commands into more intermediate key
bindings commands to more advanced key
bindings commands and so on then we're
going to talk about macros and registers
and in the end we're going to wrap up
with plugins and neovim so we're going
to talk about how to build an actual
sort of ide or at least an advanced
editor something approximating vs code
or even better using plugins and neovim
so let's get right into it
all right so let's get started with the
motivational part where i'm going to
show you or explain to you why using
them can be interesting to you and i'm
not going to talk too much here i'm just
going to show you my setup and what i
can do with it and then you can decide
if you think that's interesting or not
but before we get into that i want to
mention that this box down here um is
showing you what keys i press so right
now i'm in the terminal and i can type
abc and you can see that i'm typing abc
up here but you can also see what i'm
typing down here and you can also see
that if i press backspace for example
this is also locked here and if i press
enter it is also locked so whatever i
press whatever i type you can see down
here on the right this is important
because a lot of times uh when i do
something in vim you're going to see
certain effects but you don't really see
what i'm pressing so here on the right
you can see what kind of keys i'm
pressing in order to do certain things
and i want to show you first of all what
probably most of you know
um
vim is or no vim looks like or think
about when they think about bim and this
is essentially just the vi command so vi
and opening a file i have prepared a c
file here client dot c
and when i open this this is what
probably most of you know as vim just a
basic text editor here you don't even
know how to leave it probably uh you
don't know what to do with it you don't
know how to type with it maybe you know
how to type and how to leave but that's
it
um this is not what i'm using on a daily
basis when i talk about using them on a
daily basis what i'm using is neovim
with a couple of plugins and with my
custom settings and then it can look
like that
so nvim client c
and this is what it can look like in the
end this is just a motivation whatever i
show you here you don't need to
understand it yet i'm going to show you
maybe some key bindings i'm going to
show you some plugins you don't need to
understand them i'm just showing you
what you can do here so first of all you
can see a different theme you can see a
different airline on the bottom here so
status bar you could say i can open up a
file tree on the left here i can
navigate through directories here i can
go back here and i can open up the tag
bar which is essentially showing me the
functions i can use my mouse to jump to
certain functions uh and since this is c
i think i'm also able to open up the man
pages here i'm not sure if that works or
how that works there you go you have the
man pages up here
um so this actually doesn't look like a
terminal editor anymore this looks like
vs code uh in a different style and the
difference here is of course also that
um this is not
this is not one editor that you download
and it always looks like that and you
can change the theme this is my custom
editor i decided that i want to have a
tag bar i decided that i want to have uh
this file tree here i decided that i
want to be able to open up terminals by
typing terminal split
bash
i decided that i want to be able to do
that there you go um and i can also
decide to uninstall these plugins and i
can decide how how i want to have my
editor it's completely customizable and
um i do all of that so that's the editor
itself that's the customization what i
can do now is i can use so called vim
bindings which we're going to learn
about to do things more efficiently for
example let's say i want to delete
everything that's in between this uh
this curly bracket here and this curly
bracket how i would do it in ordinary
text editors i would go select that and
delete this what i can do here in vim is
i can let's say i'm here for example at
this point what i can do is i can just
say delete inner
and then or actually in this case um we
need to do it here delete inner curly
brackets and then it does that again you
don't need to understand the key
bindings yet we're going to learn about
them i just show you what i can do here
well let's say i'm here i don't uh i
want to delete for example the next
three words so static and get index i
want to delete them i can just type
d3w there you go i can undo here
i can do all sorts of things i can just
cut and paste using using the keyboard
without using the mouse in any
complicated ways here i can also do
something like um
i'm here i want to change everything
inside of the parentheses i can do it
like that so a couple of small things
that you might think first of all are
maybe complicated or
not really relevant because who cares if
i can delete the word by typing ciw or
by by just selecting it with a mouse but
the fact is that i personally can say
for my from my experience that i
have enjoyed a huge speed up in my
coding speed so i think that i'm at
least 300 percent faster because you
don't have to use the mouse most of the
time
and
even when using the keyboard you can do
things so efficiently and right now you
might think okay but typing certain
characters to to change for example text
inside of parentheses in isn't this kind
of confusing and it isn't in the
beginning in the first place it's
confusing but then as as you train using
vim as you use it on a daily basis at
least the key bindings you get used to
it and then all of a sudden things get
quite quickly so for example i want to
change the loop here i'm working right
now i don't even think about it i just
type ci parentheses of course not in the
insert mode
see i parentheses and there you go i
change this
or
um i don't know i want to change the
line here cc i change the whole line i
type something else whatever it is so
using vim first of all allows you to
create your own neo-vim setup if you
want to stick with vim but you can also
use them not only in vim
vim bindings are supported by a lot of
different tools so you can use vim
bindings via plugins in the jetbrains
ides you can use it in or use vim
bindings in vs code you can use them in
jupyter notebooks you can use them in
overleaf and r studio in all sorts of
applications you can use vim bindings
they're supported you don't have to
stick to the terminal if you don't like
using terminal editors you can go with
pycharm intellij whatever you want to
use and you can use vim bindings and i
guarantee you if you train them they're
going to speed up your coding speed
where they're going to increase your
coding speed
so this is my motivation for now and now
we're going to talk about the
installation
now when it comes to the installation it
all depends on what kind of operating
system you're working on if you're
working on linux or mac you probably
have them installed already or at least
you have vi the difference is that vim
means vi improved so it's a more recent
version a more improved version and you
can see if you have it by just typing vi
uh and if you see here vim vi improved
you have them installed and also bound
to vi otherwise you can try to type vim
and maybe then it says vim and then you
know you have it installed if it only
has vi and it doesn't show you that it's
vi improved so vim uh what you want to
do on linux and mac is you want to use
your package installer to install uh vim
so on debian based distributions for
example sudo apt install and then vim or
on archbase distributions pacman
s vim and so on and so forth depending
on your operating system and then you
have it in your terminal now on windows
things are a little bit different so you
can go to the powershell for example you
can install it via the powershell and
inside of the powershell so then you
have an actual
terminal editor vim
you can install it via gvm so just
download the graphical user interface to
vim or my preferred way of doing it is
using the windows subsystem for linux so
actually running linux inside of windows
not with a virtual box but with the
windows subsystem for linux which is
provided by microsoft so you just go to
the store you download it you install it
you can watch a tutorial on that i'm not
going to make one here because this is
about vim but you basically install the
windows subsystem for linux and then you
follow the linux steps so just sudo apt
install
and then bim
so this is how you install it that's it
for the installation part now we're
going to start with the basics
all right so let's start working with
vim the first thing we want to do is we
want to open a file and for that we just
type vi or vim depending on your aliases
and then a file name for example
client.c which is the file from before
now in this case vim is going to open
the file for editing we can change some
stuff we can save it we can dismiss
changes and so on if we type some file
name or some file path that that does
not exist what's going to happen is that
we're going to create a new file so if i
type not client c but something like
test.txt
this is going to create a new file this
is going to open a blank file and once i
write the changes to the file this file
is going to be created by them so let's
start now with client.c and the first
question that most people have when they
enter vim is how do i get out of it so
i'm going to tell you that right away
all you need to do is you need to type
colon cue and then enter
now the problem is that most people try
a lot of things before actually being
able to um to get some help or someone
who tells them how to leave them so they
open up a new file test.txt
and they just press a thousand keys they
don't know what to do
uh and all that
and then someone tells them okay
press colonqueue and then you're going
to leave them however this is not going
to work here because if i press colon q
enter you can see that it says no write
since last change at exclamation mark to
overwrite
so essentially all you need to do in
this case is you need to say q and then
exclamation mark and this is because you
want to say with this exclamation mark
you're saying quit but also dismiss any
changes that i made so if you make any
changes you cannot just quit them is not
going to allow that you have to say okay
i ignore all the changes just forget
about those there you go
the important thing is here that you
don't type exclamation mark q but q
exclamation mark and the reason for that
is that when you type exclamation mark
and then something this is a terminal
command so for example i can say
i don't know what can i do ls for
example this is going to give me the ls
command from the terminal and if i type
exclamation mark q this is not going to
quit this is just going to execute a
command that is not known because q is
not a command so if you want to leave
you just type q and then exclamation
mark if you want to dismiss the changes
what if you don't want to dismiss the
changes let's say i want to open up
test.txt and i want to write something
first of all how do i write something
because by default if i press for
example the key d
we don't write these and also c we don't
write c's okay now we write c's but if i
press c once we don't write c's
so why is that and how can we start
typing some text
in order to understand this you need to
understand that vim works with so-called
modes so when we open a new file we are
in the normal mode or when when we enter
vim we are in the normal mode and in the
normal mode every key has its
functionality for example the colon key
starts a command so if i want to type a
command like quit for example or write
or doing something um or setting
something i need to type colon and then
whatever i want to execute and then i
press enter to execute that vim command
so the colon the colon is actually what
i press in order to execute a command in
the normal mode because if you're in a
different mode keys have different
functionalities but in a normal mode if
you type colon in something you execute
a command once you press enter
another key like d for example is for
deleting or a is for appending and so on
and so forth we're going to talk about
those but the first things you need to
know is that i and enters the insert
mode if you press the letter i or the
character i what happens is you get into
insert mode you can see here down on the
right i pressed i am now in the insert
mode which you can see here on the
bottom left
insert mode means that whatever i press
now doesn't have a functionality but
it's just text so i can write stuff here
i can also press i i don't get into
another insert mode i can press colon i
don't get into command mode insert mode
means that i can type text
now if i want to leave the insert mode
again into the normal mode i press
escape so by pressing escape we leave
the insert mode and we get into normal
mode and now again if i type colon i
have a command
and if i type i i enter the insert mode
escape get out of it again and so on and
now i have some text let's say i want to
save this first of all if i'm in the
insert mode i need to get out of it by
pressing escape and then i can say colon
w which is for write so if i want to
write the changes into a file i press w
and i can press enter
like that and you can see that uh these
characters were written into the file
however i can also do write and quit so
for example let's say i change something
here
and i want to say quit and it says no
write since last change i can override
it with the exclamation mark again i can
also do wq so write and quit in this
case it writes the changes into the file
and it also quits so i can go ahead now
and open the file again
and you can see
that all the changes are still in the
file
so this is how you can do basic stuff in
vim this is how you get into the insert
mode and this is how you get out of the
insert mode into the normal mode
now
each character as i already said has
different functionality or has a
different functionality so the insert
mode basically means or i basically
means i enter the insert mode but there
are multiple keys that enter the insert
mode for example another one would be a
a also enters the insert mode or o o can
also enter the insert mode the
difference is how they enter the insert
mode for example let's say i have here
um one two three four five six seven
eight nine
and
i'm focusing on the five here my cursor
is above the five and i press i which
you can see is that i if i type a now
the a is placed between four and five so
when i press i i go before
the cursor before the actual focused
number if i'm focusing the five and now
i press a instead of i
i focus on the six so if i type an a now
you can see that the a ends up between
five and six
and if i type o
i open a new line below that line and
then i enter the insert mode so for
example i'm up here and i press o this
creates a new line and i'm in insert
mode and i don't have to be at the end
of the line so it's not like saying
enter uh because uh when you say enter
you just go to the end of the line
whatever
you press enter you also open a new line
it's not the case here what's the case
here is that wherever i am in the line
so even here i press o it opens a new
line and i'm in the insert mode
so we have i for inserting before the
cursor a for inserting after the cursor
so appending and o for opening a new
line or for creating a new line below
the line now these three characters can
also be used with the shift key in order
to have a capital letter so capital i
capital a and capital o
and the functionality here is a little
bit different so for example if i'm
focusing the 5 and i type shift i or i
press shift i
this enters the insert mode at the
beginning of
at the beginning of this line so
the a is here no matter where i am so
even if i have multiple words here with
spaces and all that if i'm somewhere in
the middle here and i press capital i
what you see is i jump to the beginning
of the line and then i type here
the opposite happens with capital a
capital a goes to the end of the line
appends to the end of the line
and enters the insert mode and capital o
doesn't open a line below the current
line but above like that so if i'm here
at this line and i press capital o it
opens a line above and enters the insert
mode so those are the very basic changes
how you can change from the normal mode
into the insert mode and from the insert
mode into the normal mode you always
press escape basically
this is how you can do that
now before we move on to other key
bindings i want to
talk a little bit about settings here
because you can see that this is really
not an attractive editor and it's not
going to be without plugins it's not
going to be an attractive editor but we
can make it more attractive so first of
all what i like to have is some line
numbers if you want to have some line
numbers in vim what you do is you type
colon
set
and then
blank or white space number
set number basically activates line
number so if i press enter now you can
see that we have line numbers on the
left
now one thing that you're going to see
in vim as we go on over time
is that
line numbers or actually not line
numbers but numbers can be used to
combine key bindings a very basic
example we're going to talk about more
examples a very basic example is that
each action can be repeated x times so
for example if i press the key down so
the arrow key down
i move one line down but if i type 5 and
then arrow key down i move five lines
down i can do the same thing with up so
seven up goes seven lines up and in this
line i can do it with left and right so
let's say i'm here i can say 15 right
and it jumps 15 characters to the right
by the way one thing that i want to
mention here as well is that and this is
something where i'm not actually doing
um the usual thing that you do as a vim
user especially as a hardcore vim user
uh this is the the part where i'm
probably too soft i'm using the arrow
keys uh just because i don't type with
10 fingers yet
but what you can do in bim is you can
use the h j k and l key
instead of the arrow keys so k goes up j
goes down
h goes left and l goes right so
essentially the idea behind that is not
some arbitrary keys those are four keys
in a line and essentially the reason for
using those keys instead of using the
arrow keys is that you don't have to
leave the main keyboard space so
vim is all about optimizing your typing
speed your coding speed so you want to
type as fast as possible you want to use
10 fingers
optimally i'm not doing it but you want
to use 10 fingers
and you want to leave this space as
solemnly as possible you don't want to
go to the mouse you don't want to go to
the arrow keys you want to stay there
and this means that you're going to have
to use jk l and h in order to move
around instead of the arrow keys but
again i'm not doing that uh usually so
uh you you can do that better
but again these numbers can be combined
also with the j and k so if i go if i
type k it goes one up if i type 4k it
goes four up so you can combine numbers
with key bindings in order to to repeat
them
now why am i telling you that because
this happens quite often and
a setting there there is a certain
setting that you can use in order to
make this easier
uh with some key bindings and this
setting is called relative number and
not everyone is going to like it i'm i'm
probably i'm pretty sure that most of
you who don't use vim or haven't used
them yet you're not going to like this
setting but it is quite useful in this
setting is set relative number
and essentially
instead of getting the absolute line
numbers you get the relative line
numbers to the current line so for the
current line you see that you have the
line number four so you get the actual
line number but for the other lines you
get the relative line number so you can
see this line number here or this line
here is five lines away so if i type
five
down i jump to that line and this can be
quite useful because this can be
combined with deletion this can be
combined with um with pasting with
copying and so on
um and we're going to talk about this
uh as we go on here but this is just
something that you can activate if you
want to you don't have to
but you can use the set relative number
setting here
or you can just use the set number
setting without the set relative number
setting and we can do a couple of
different things so by default for
example i cannot use the mouse here if i
want to use the mouse i have to set the
mouse to active so set mouse equals a
and then i can press around here i can
also scroll
other things would be for example
setting the
tab stop to four
setting the shift width to four and so
on or choosing a color scheme so color
scheme slate for example you can just
type color scheme and then tap to see
the different color schemes that we have
here and then you can pick one enter and
you can change the color scheme
now before i show you too many commands
here
what happens when i close this here
let's write and close what happens is i
open them up again
and all the settings are gone
so you can type whatever you want you
don't have the settings so if i type set
number and i leave and i open it up
again i don't have the numbers anymore
and of course if you have like 20
settings you don't want to set them all
the time every time you open vim so you
want to have a settings file a
configuration file that does it for you
and for that you have the vim rc file
which is located at the following place
you go to uh or actually i'm not gonna
see d there i'm gonna i'm gonna vim
there so i'm gonna go with vim there uh
which is the user directory and then
slash dot vim rc
now
this is the file this is the path so vim
recognizes that path user directory
slash dot them rc
if the file is there vim loads it or
them is going to open it if it's not
there you create it and vim is still
going to load it so we're going to open
up the vimrc file in this case we don't
have it it's a new file we're going to
enter the insert mode and i'm just going
to write here a couple of settings set
number
set
relative number set
um
tap stop
equal to four set
shift
width equal to four
set auto indent
i think most of them
except for the for the first two are
self-explanatory then set mouse equal to
a and color scheme
slate for example
so
colon w colon wq whatever
and then i can open up now again the bim
dots or the test.txt file and you can
see that i have the settings loaded i
have the relative line numbers i have
the line numbers i have the color scheme
and i have also the shift width and the
tab stop which we cannot see here um but
this is how you do it you can create
this vimrc file or change this vmrc file
every time you want to change or change
something for example if i say i don't
want to use this anymore i want to use
something else
i can delete the color scheme and go
with uh what do we have here was delic
was that a color scheme i'm not sure
yeah or no actually not color scheme
that look it was a color scheme okay um
whatever you can change this config file
however you want i like to use slate
from the default themes later on we can
install some with plugins but those are
the very basics opening files closing
files writing to files entering into the
insert mode leaving the insert mode back
into the normal mode and then also
having some basic settings moving around
and those are the very very basics of
them
all right so what we're going to do now
is we're going to look at a lot of vim
key bindings and vim key functions and
this can be quite a lot of information
to digest for a beginner and it might be
frustrating and confusing because you're
not going to remember everything at once
i'm going to show a lot here you don't
have to remember everything at once what
i recommend you do is you watch the
whole video and then once you start
training them you go to google and you
type vim cheat sheets or bim cheat sheet
and then you look for a cheat sheet that
um has a couple of the things that you
want to train for example i think this
one is quite good here
from phoenix nap we're not affiliated um
and essentially you can see here moving
inserting editing copying cutting
pasting marking and so on you have the
basic commands the basic key bindings
here and you can train them you don't
have to remember them here from the
video this video is for an overview you
can play around you can learn the things
but you don't have to remember
everything by watching this video so
we're going to start out with the key
bindings here uh let's open a file again
not nvm we're going to use vi
test.txt again and now we have the text
that we have here first of all let me
show you some basic keys like undoing
and redoing let's say you write
something we're going to use o to open a
new line here in the insert mode and i
type hello world for example i use
escape to go back to the normal mode if
i want to undo this right now what i
have to do is i cannot do control z
because control z in the terminal gets
you out of um
out of the process so it puts it into
the background so you don't want to do
that you want to type u so just pressing
the key u in normal mode undo's that so
you can see down here it says okay this
happened 23 seconds ago we have two
fewer lines now and this basically undid
the action now if i want to repeat the
action so if i want to redo the action
what i do is i press control
r control r reduce and you undo's so
ctrl r redo now let's add a couple of
things here
hello then maybe
what
then inserting again here is going to
normal again
up question mark going into normal again
uh now i can press u u u u u
or control r r or control r control r
control r control r
and what i can also do is remember we
can combine numbers and commands i can
also say three u to go three undo's back
or three redos
uh you can see again here what i'm
typing
um or i can say five u for five undos
and of course if there are no undues to
do anymore you can see already at all
this change and i can do control r
already at newest change
um so this is basic undoing and redoing
now what's also interesting is uh this
is now not related to undoing and
redoing is this is a third mode that we
introduced here because this can be
quite useful we know now that we have an
insert mode and we also know that we
have a normal mode so insert again we
enter it with i a or o
and we can leave that with escape but
there's also a third mode called the
visual mode and the visual mode is for
selecting now let's say for example i'm
here now and i want to select this this
second word here even though it's not a
word what i can do is i can press v for
visual mode you can see down here it
says visual and now if i go right i
select the word and now i can do certain
things with that word i can delete it i
can copy it i can uh cut it i can i can
do a couple of things with that word so
now i have selected it if i want to
delete it what i do is i press d
d is the deletion key so if i press d it
deletes something
i can undo it again now with u and i can
also of course if i'm in the visual mode
i can just press escape
in this case twice
to to leave the visual mode so again
selecting this d deletes it and i can
also select just a couple of characters
here d deletes those
now if i want to copy so i can also take
that and press y
y is the key that we use for yanking
this is what it's called in in vim and
yanking means copying so if i press y it
says or doesn't say anything but it
copied them and now i can go down here
for example i can press p
and it enters or it inserts it it pastes
basically what i yanked before
and i can do that a couple of times i
can press ppp or i can also press of
course
10
10 p
there you go
and i can undo all of that again
so every command almost every command
every key can be combined with a number
and then it's going to be repeated so
again
let's select this here with visual mode
y for yanking and then 4p for pasting it
four times
um and then again i can also select all
of this here and just press d in order
to remove it
now
these commands here or these key
bindings can be used in different ways
so y is for yanking d is for deleting
and p is for pasting and i can use them
in different ways so for example
i can select something
and i can say d as we did before or i
can just press d d to delete the whole
line so undo again dd deletes the whole
line dd
dd and of course again if i go up here
for example and i say 5 dd it deletes
five lines
there you go
um
same can be done with copying in this
case it doesn't make a lot of sense to
to copy multiple times but i can copy
full line so not just selecting and
copying i can yank a full line by going
y y and yy yanks the full line i can go
down here and say p
and then i can say also 5p and it adds
these five lines with
line breaks because i yank the whole
line so also the line break
um
[Music]
that is that
what else do we have i can use paste in
the upper case way so i can also this is
the same as o uppercase o and lowercase
o if i copy let's say this line here and
i now say p
it's pasted below the what if i say
uppercase p it goes above that
uh and of course also if i if i copy
just a word without um without these new
line characters i can press p to to
paste at the end of the
at the end of the of the cursor and i
can paste i can press capital p to go
before that so same thing as i and a
essentially
so that is that now sometimes what we
want to do is we don't want to delete a
line we want to change a line so the
difference between deleting and changing
is not too much it's essentially the
same thing but the difference is that we
enter the insert mode when we change so
if i just want to delete this line i
press dd and the line is gone if i want
to delete the line but also change it so
i want to change what the line is i
press cc
and this changes the line so you can see
the line is not vanished i'm in the
insert mode and i can type some stuff
here so cc enters the insert mode and
doesn't delete the line whereas dd
deletes the full line here
and c can also be used in the visual
mode so i can select for example here
the world and i can press c and you can
see i'm still in insert mode and i can
type whereas if i select this and i type
d i leave the visual mode i'm in normal
mode and not in insert mode
so those are the differences and we can
also use the uppercase characters so i
can type
for example if i'm here now and i press
uppercase d
this deletes the rest of the line not
the full line if you want to delete the
full line again dd if you want to delete
just a part of the line namely the last
part from this cursor up until the end
capital d deletes the rest of the line
and capital c changes the rest of the
line
that is that but i think uppercase y as
far as i know copies the full line yeah
uppercase y doesn't copy the rest of the
line but the full line so uppercase y is
essentially the same as y y
um
that is that and last but not least when
it comes or last last but not least for
the deletion and the replacing is
actually the replacing um character
which is r so let's say i'm here with
hello and i want to change the h what i
can do is i can just press r and r means
replace and if i now press k
you can see that it says kello instead
of hello
now what's what's what's the purpose of
that the purpose is just that i can use
the r key and i don't have to
delete and then enter a new character
because in ordinary editors what you do
is you go into the insert mode or you
don't go into insert mode you already
have the insert mode you delete one
character and you replace it so i delete
the h and i press the k to enter it in
vim i can just press r
and then h to change the k to an h
so that's that
now all these things like deleting
changing copying and so on can be used
more efficiently if we have some keys or
some key functions that allow us to move
in an advanced way and this is what
we're going to introduce next let's say
we have a simple sentence here hello i
am a simple
sentence period what i can do now is of
course i can use the arrow keys or h j k
l to move around here
um but what i can also do is i can jump
words for example so this is this is
something i can do in in vim i can jump
words forwards and backwards so if i'm
here i can just press w to jump to the
next word i can press w again to jump to
the next word and so on and so forth i
just press w and it jumps to the next
word uh essentially word meaning i'm not
sure what the exact definition is but as
far as i know word means either a space
or some special character in between so
i think if you have something like hello
i
am
a simple
sentence even though we don't have a
blank here this should
i think no in this case it doesn't um
consider that as multiple words but i
think if we have
now i'm using by the way the r to to
change the individual characters here i
think that if i use hyphens as hyphens
as you can see
those are considered to be individual
words
however if i go and use uppercase w
this is one word so if i have something
here uppercase w says this is one word
and those are individual words so the
basic difference is that if you use
uppercase w you jump um or a word is
considered to be
something that is separated by by spaces
so if there's no space it's considered
to be one word whereas the lowercase w
considers also stuff like hyphens to be
separators for words
now the same thing can be done backwards
so if i'm here and i want to go back a
word i basically just type b so b b b or
if i want to consider this a full word i
can type uppercase b so uppercase b
there you go this is one word so the
same thing that w does forwards b does
backwards
um now why is this useful
this is useful because we can use it
together with the things that we learned
about already and this is where when vim
gets very very interesting now for
example the d key is the deletion key
and what exactly i delete can be
specified so for example again if i mark
something in the visual mode this is
what i'm deleting if i press dd i'm
deleting the whole line but what i can
also do is i can say dw delete a word dw
deletes a word and of course i can say 2
dw
delete two words
or in this in this case it was basically
two times delete a word i can also say
d2w for delete two words essentially
this means that where am i when i say
two w it jumps there everything up until
this point is deleted so d two w delete
two words
or also if i'm at this point here i can
say delete to b to go two words
backwards and delete
the respective words
however you will notice that if i'm in
the middle of a word and i say dw it
won't delete the full word but just the
remaining part of the word if i want to
delete the full word i have to type
delete in a word so d i w delete in a
word
um and same goes for change so for
example if i'm somewhere here and i want
to say okay i want to change this here
to something else the rest is okay uh i
just type c i w change in a word and i
can type something instead now you may
you may say now that this is not really
useful because who needs that and all
all that but this is actually quite
useful i use it on an everyday basis
when i use a jetbrain environment when i
use vs code when i use neovam doesn't
really matter i constantly use these key
bindings because they really speed up
your code or they really increase your
coding speed
so remember you can specify
the movements using w and b or also one
thing that i didn't introduce yet yet is
e e jumps to the end of a word so if i
type e it jumps to the end of a word and
also we have uh the same thing for the
line so if i want to jump to the
beginning of the line
as a movement not as inserting so
remember with capital i i can go to the
beginning of a line into the insert mode
but if i just want to jump there to
specify for example for a delete command
i press 0 0 goes to the beginning of a
line and the dollar symbol goes to the
end of the line again all this you don't
have to remember it right now just hear
about this and then you can look it up
in a cheat sheet again but what's
interesting part here is that if i'm
here for example and i type d0
everything up until or everything to the
beginning or everything until the
beginning
is being deleted from the current point
and the same thing goes if i'm here for
example
and i say d
dollar d dollar basically means delete
until the end of the line and i can do
the same thing with the end of the word
so i can say d
e which is actually the same thing as
saying dw in this case
um but this is what we can do here
and uh with with a capital e we can do
the same thing with
words only considered to be words if
they have spaces around them
or actually not accepting any other
separators except for spaces
so again a lot of information to digest
here so i'm going to repeat it you can
jump around with w you can jump around
with b and you can combine these jumps
you can also jump around with e uh you
can combine all of these jumps with
deletion with copying and with
uh changing and all sorts of things so
for example let's say i want to copy
this word here and i'm in the middle of
the word what i do is i say y i
w
yank inner word
and then i can go down here for example
p
and i now have the word copied here
again this is very useful because
oftentimes
you are coding right now you don't want
to leave the keyboard and you're here
now and you want to change this okay
just ciw there you go i don't have to do
the the okay let's select all this here
and let's press uh delete the delete key
here and then let's type something else
i can just while i'm in the middle of
the word i can just type something like
now i have to jump to the word i can
just type ciw and i change it right
now where this gets really interesting
is
when we go into parentheses and brackets
and other symbols so for example you
might have some python function print
hello world this is my stupid message
and since the message is stupid you want
to delete it you want to change it and
you're inside of these parentheses now
what you usually do is first of all you
go to the beginning then you use the uh
the shift key and the arrow keys to mark
all that or maybe use the mouse to
select all of this here and then you
delete it what you can do here with vim
is you can just go somewhere into the
middle and you type c
i and then
quotation marks change inner quotation
marks and you can type something else
right
change inner quotation marks so if you
don't want to change it you can also say
delete in a quotation marks without
entering the insert mode or you can also
say
yank
inner quotations
and then you can paste it somewhere
right so this is just very convenient
and you can do the same thing with uh
with parentheses with square brackets
with curly brackets so for example if i
wanna if i want to change everything
here inside of the parentheses i just
type c i change inner parentheses and i
can use the opening or closing
parentheses or bracket it doesn't really
matter
so
again hello world then maybe we have
multiple parameters abc one two three
whatever i want to change all this here
just c i
and then opening bracket
so this can be very very useful and i
use this quite often uh what else do we
have here now we can combine all of this
again with numbers i think i mentioned
this already but everything that i show
you here can be combined with numbers so
i delete
five words and i can also five times
delete five words you can do whatever
you want actually
and you can also copy five lines so you
can say five yy
then p and you have copied five lines
and so on all this can be combined with
numbers
now let's look at a couple of different
things and for this maybe let's go to
the uh to the client c file
here we can see how this is useful i
showed it already in the motivation now
let's say i want to change the function
signature here i'm not i'm not going to
do anything meaningful here but let's
say i want to change the parameters here
ci parentheses there you go
now also there's another operator that
we haven't talked about yet or another
key that we can press here um if i'm at
this
if i'm focusing on this uh curly bracket
here so here
and i want to know okay where is the
closing one first of all it's displayed
here you can see that it's highlighted
but also i can jump to it by using the
percentage sign so i can type percent to
jump to that place and of course if i
have huge functions like i should have
one down here here this is the opening
bracket and if i type percent i go to
the closing bracket if i type it again i
jump up again so this is very very
useful
for jumping and of course guess what
happens when i type d percent it deletes
everything including the bracket that we
have
down there
um
yeah so another jump that we can do is
we can jump not a word or uh not to a
certain
certain um bracket that is closing but
to a certain character so for example
you might say okay i'm here
and i want to delete everything until
the next star symbol comes so i just
type or actually before we start
deleting let's jump to the next star
symbol how do i do that i say t
star t start gets me to the position
before the symbol that i specify so if
i'm somewhere here in the same line by
in the same line by the way so if i say
t star i jump one position before the
star if i say f star this is find
it jumps to that position so that's a
difference
why is that important um because let's
say i want to delete this switch here
now in this case it's just a word let's
say we have a couple of more things i
have some nonsense here whatever and i
want to delete everything up until the
opening bracket what i can do is i can
say d
t
and opening bracket and then it deletes
everything up until this point if i do
the same thing with f it's a problem
because then it's going to also delete
the brackets so i can say uh df
opening bracket and then we don't have
the bracket anymore so maybe that's not
want to do but t and f are for finding
or jumping one position before that so t
jumps one position before the specified
symbol
uh before the next current occurrence in
the same line of the specified symbol
and f jumps onto that
that's the difference here
now
um
i think what capital t does what does
capital t do
oh yeah capital t goes backwards so
capital t and capital f do the same
thing just backwards so t
our lowercase t and start jumps to the
next star and uppercase t and star jumps
before to the or after the previous star
you could say so you can see one
position after that and if i type
capital f star it jumps to the star that
comes before the current cursor
uh that is that and again this can be
combined with with deleting with yanking
i can also say for example i wanna copy
everything up until the openings uh
curly bracket they go so i basically
typed
uh in this case
oh by the way you you see here i i just
noticed that you see here ctrl alt d7
this is just because on my keyboard i'm
using a german layout uh this was just a
curly bracket so if i type switch
if i if i type yank t
and then curly bracket and i pay and i
press p now this
copied exactly what i wanted to copy
so this is how we can use that
um and one last thing for this section
here that i want to show you is how to
jump uh to the beginning of a file to
the end of a file into a certain line
number so we're somewhere here right now
291 if i want to jump to the beginning
of the file i type gg so lowercase gg
like good game and if i want to jump to
the end of the line or to the end of the
file i type
shift g and it goes to the end and if i
want to jump to a specific line i can
type that line so for example one two
three
and uppercase g
then i jump to that or i can use a
command so i can type colon
406
enter and it jumps to that line
so i would say that what we have covered
up until now are the basics of them so
the fundamental key bindings the
fundamental commands and so on and now
we're going to move to some more
intermediate stuff now once you start
actually practicing them so actually
using them on a daily basis to practice
it um i would recommend focusing on the
fundamentals first and then moving on to
the intermediate stuff but for this
video you can keep watching to get an
overview but once you start training
focus on the fundamentals first
so for the intermediate stuff we're
going to cover a quite diverse set of
things so we're going to talk about some
indentation formatting stuff we're going
to talk about searching we're going to
talk about replacing um and i want to
start here with the indentation so with
the shifting offline so for example
let's say i'm in this line here like
line number 400 i want to shift it to
the right or i want to indent it to the
right
now before i show you the command i want
to mention that the program here on the
bottom right doesn't translate these
keys correctly so i hope that
this is not too confusing essentially
what i'm pressing here is in order to
shift a line that i'm currently at to
the right i use two times the closing
bracket now this translates properly but
the opening bracket doesn't translate
properly so this is the opening bracket
for me
so look here not here to the bottom
right
and if i use this here so the first line
this indents to the right
as you can see
and this here indents to the left so if
i do this all the time it indents to the
left
and these things now so you have to
press twice if you're just at the line
if you have selected the line you can
just press it once so if i use the
visual mode to select this here
um i think i just have to press once and
then it's going to indent it and i can
select it again and i press once back to
put it to the left
now at this point i also want to mention
that there are multiple visual modes now
up until now we have only used just the
normal visual mode just pressing v and
selecting some some area here
we can also use the visual line mode and
the visual block mode the visual line
mode i think it's quite
self-explanatory we press shift v and we
select light so we cannot select parts
of lines we select full lines like that
and then we can just press y and then
press p and paste that part and all that
um
but essentially that that is the visual
line mode the visual block mode is
something that i have to admit don't use
too often but it can be quite useful if
you need it it's essentially the same
thing as a line mode but column wise so
i can press ctrl v
to go into the
uh in this case i think okay
this doesn't work in this case because i
have overwritten it
all right so the problem was with the
windows terminal not with vim
so i opened up another terminal here and
i'm going to open another file here
when you are in a file in normal mode
and you press control v you enter the
visual block mode and you can select
column wise like that and then you can
press d to delete the columns and so on
um this is not what you do in a visual
mode and this is not what you do in the
visual line mode this is what you do in
the visual block mode which is control v
and then
you select um
all these lines here
as you can see now we can change them
and we can
or you can delete them and uh yeah in
this case we changed them so we entered
also
at all these lines something all right
so back in the previous editor we can
not only shift lines manually by
shifting them left and right we can also
automatically indent and this works
better with languages like c or java
that have
brackets around their code it doesn't
work too well with python because then
again you don't know okay what's the
proper indentation do i have to indent
here or not but in this case let's say
we have a badly formatted code so let's
say this is somewhere here which is
still correct code right but it's it's
just ugly
and maybe we have something here
how can i do this here like that
and maybe we have something like that
and like that now if i want to auto
indent a line i just have to go to that
line and type the equal sign so not less
than not greater than just equal twice
so if i type equal twice
um this is indented correctly there you
go
and let me just reverse this here
this can also be done for uh an area so
let me just repeat
the mess here and i can just use the
visual line mode to select a section and
then once i have selected a section i
just type
um
i just press the equal sign and you can
see everything is indented and this also
works with the full file so i can
combine now a couple of things here let
me just mess up the code a little bit
and let's remember the line here
where all of this starts here 406. now
in order to auto indent the full file
what i do is i type gg to move to the
beginning of the file then i type equals
and then capital g to move to the end of
the file so indent until the end of the
file and now this was what was it 406 g
there you go everything is indented
properly here
so this worked this is auto annotation
now let us move to searching searching
is basically like jumping but instead of
just jumping to the next character that
you find you jump to the next search
term and searching in vim is done using
the slash uh characters so it's done
like a colon you will see that something
pops up down in the bottom if you type
slash and here you can type for example
hello and if i press enter in this case
it doesn't find hello because in this
code we don't have hello but maybe if i
type url
it finds url in this case now this is
one url if i want to jump to the next
url that it finds i press n so n jumps
to the next and i can do this a couple
of times i can jump through all the urls
here
there you go there you go there you go
and i can also go back so if i want to
go to the previous i go capital n
capital n to go back up
and then just escape
or actually doesn't really matter escape
because the url stays
safe here now in some color schemes this
is going to stay marked you just
type slash again and you enter some
nonsense there are some fancy ways to
reset it but this is basically how
everyone does it um if you want to
search backwards so not the next
occurrence but the previous occurrence
you use the question mark so question
mark url
and uh you basically the normal n
basically moves up now and the capital
end moves down now so this is just the
reverse of that
um
what we can also do is we can select a
token
um how does this work let me just type
something else here so that we reset it
so if i press n we don't find url now
now i can select url and i can type uh
hashtag
oh actually this is still individual
mode now i have this token i type
hashtag to find the next occurrence of
that token so hashtag goes
up in this case again this this doesn't
translate properly it says that i'm
pressing a question mark so don't be
confused by that but
this hashtag basically means moving up
and if i go with star
star goes to the next one
so star goes to the next occurrence of
the token so here if i go to length and
i press star it goes to the next length
length length there you go
and hashtag goes up again again hashtag
what i'm actually typing here is this
character here
not the question mark
um
so that is that what do we have else now
we can we can do something quite
interesting which is marking locations
and jumping to those locations so let's
say for example
um
i frequently revisit a function for some
reason for example extract hostname here
and especially this line 130 this cursor
here i come here quite often what i can
do is i can mark that as a waypoint so i
can set a waypoint by typing m and i can
now choose a character for example uh m
a which would mark this as being the
mark a and if i now am at a certain
different position here
and i want to jump to a certain way
point i just press this uh single
quotation mark here
and then a and then it jumps there and i
can also go to a different point here
for example extract full status to this
string copy here m and i can type g so
mg in this case now i go somewhere else
and i can type
single quotation a single quotation g
and this can be used to mark important
sections in the code to jump through
them and to not have to scroll all the
time or remember line numbers you can
just say okay
jump to the waypoint a there i have a
certain piece of code jump to waypoint k
there i have a certain code section and
so on you can navigate through large
code files using these uh waypoints
now another little thing that we can do
is we can center the current selection
so if i'm down here you can see it
doesn't scroll necessarily just because
i move my mouse here or move my cursor
here uh if i want to center the current
line so i want to move it up into the
screen i just type zz so two times
lowercase z and then it's centered it is
and this can be quite useful especially
if you have something like
a new
file um
let's just remove all this here
and now let's say i go down somewhere
and i don't really have anything to
scroll down to
what i can do is i can type zz to still
center that even though there are no
lines below that
so let us move back to the c file the
last two things that i want to show you
here for the intermediate category are
searching and replacing so basically
just substituting and repeating a
command so substituting strings and
repeating commands um and for that let's
take some string that occurs quite often
for example character here you can see
character occurs quite often let's take
that and replace each occurrence with
another string how do we do that in vim
with a command so we need to type colon
and then percent to make it into full
file not just in a selection not just in
the current line but in the full file
and then we type s for substitute
slash for character
and then slash and let's replace
character with symbol for example a
synonym and then slash g and once we do
that i press enter and you can see all
the occurrences here have changed across
all lines in the full file now let's say
i want to do something similar but just
in a selection let's say i want to
select this area here and let's say
do we have a word that occurs
a couple of times um
[Music]
let's just take symbol again and do it
do it and rename it to something else
now we select that and then we type
again colon
and this time we don't use percent we
just use s we don't want to do it in a
full file we just want to do it in the
selection so s slash symbol slash
something
slash g there you go here it changed
here it didn't change so this is how you
do that
and the last thing that i want to show
you here for the intermediate category
is repeating a command this is actually
quite simple let's say i delete a line
by typing dd
all i need to do in order to delete
another line is to press the period or
the dot so the point basically this
executes the command that i just
executed so this just repeats the
command but this is not a macro this is
just the last command so this is just a
single command not a sequence of
commands so
also for example if i say
uh
change until
or let's let's go here for example yeah
let's do it here um delete
until
the
um
quotation i do it here and now i can go
somewhere else maybe we have uh some
similar
let's say here for example i just press
period and it does the same thing so
this is just
um repeating the command
so the last thing that i want to talk
about here when it comes to vim bindings
and vim commands is macros and registers
and this is quite an interesting topic
because
um essentially whenever we delete
something or whenever we we copy
something whenever we yank something you
could say this is stored into a register
and we can see the list of registers in
vim by typing the command colon rec so
colon rack enter and you can see here
the individual registers you can see the
name of the register and you can see the
content of that specific register
now one thing i'm not sure if i
mentioned that whenever you delete
something using d
it is also copied so if i say uh if i if
i go to a certain line here for example
return negative one and i say dd i
delete that line but i can also paste it
again because it is also copied so
deleting in vim means copying at the
same time so basically deleting means
cutting you could say
and if you want to have multiple
clipboards in bim you basically have
that because if i delete something and
if i copy something i have the different
registers that store these things now i
can also let's let's go ahead again and
see rack here
i can also choose a certain register to
paste from so for example if i want to
paste this here the register 7 return
the full status length this is a comment
if i want to do that all i have to do is
not just press p in order to paste but
before that press
quotation mark 7 p so take the register
quotation mark 7 and paste from that i
can do the same thing with copying i can
go to that line and say quotation marks
7 y y to yank the line into 7.
register they go 7 get hostname length
function
so this is how that works oh i actually
didn't want to leave that file
and there are some special registers for
example the register with
with the name quotation mark plus
essentially means that
uh or essentially represents the
clipboard whenever you copy something in
your system provided that vim is
integrated with your system of course um
but when you copy something it is stored
in the register
which is quotation mark plus this is the
register so you can use that to copy
into the clipboard from them or to paste
uh from the clipboard in bim this is
something you can do and also something
that's quite interesting is again when
you delete something
you already have it ready for pasting
but what for example if i want to just
copy this line here so the static end i
just type y y to yank that line so i can
paste it as you can see
but i also want to delete that line and
still paste what i just copied so i want
to delete here if i just p if i just
press p
uh i just press p and i and i paste what
i just deleted
um if i want to paste the last thing
that i copied that i actually yanked i
have to use the zero register so i type
uh what was its uh quotation mark zero p
and it pastes the last thing that i
actually yanked not that was copied by
cutting or deleting this is important
now
when it comes to macros macros are
actually also stored in registers and we
can store them in registers manually so
a macro is essentially just a sequence
of vim bindings of bim actions you could
say for example uh what could be such a
thing i could go here to a certain line
and the macro would be delete
delete three words there you go
and then
go to the end of the line and
add 100 for example whatever this is a
stupid macro doesn't have any value but
if i want to record that macro what i do
is i press q
to to define that i want to start
recording a q a means record the macro a
you can see down here recording a and
now i can do whatever i want to do so
every action i take now is going to be
part of the macro for example delete
three words
capital a to jump at the end of the line
into insert mode and then
100 escape
now i want to quit the macro
cue
quit recording now the macro is stored
in a
and i think we should also see that in
the register here you can see that the
macro that register a has d3wa100
as a macro this is those are the keys
that i just typed
and they're now stored in the macro 8.
if i want to execute that macro all i
need to do is i need to to use the at
symbol so the mail symbol i hope this is
translated correctly here okay it isn't
in my case um but essentially this is
what you get on american keyboards by
pressing shift and two
so essentially just this add sign here
this is what you press
and
uh what you do in order to execute the
macro is you go to a line where you want
to execute it for example this line here
and you type at a and as you can see
deleted three words and added 100 at the
end of the line again at a
at a and so on and i think we should
even be able to use
the point now
yeah we can use even the period now no
actually not this is just repeating the
last character forget what i said just
at a
and at a this executes the macro and of
course what you can do here uh is you
can also define a macro b that does
something else and then you can define a
macro c that executes macro a and b so
you can you can combine them you can you
can have a so-called you could say
composite pattern where you have um
one macro using five other macros that
again use five other macros so you can
make pretty complicated things here and
this can be quite useful i have used it
a couple of times already
and those are i would say the basic
intermediate and advanced things that
you need to know about vim itself
now finally last but not least i want to
show you how you can take the simple
primitive vim and turn it into an actual
advanced editor into something maybe
even approximating an ide with a lot of
plugins
and
before you do that though keep in mind
that if you're starting out with vim if
you're learning it for the first time i
recommend you stick to the vanilla
version for the first couple of weeks so
you just learn the basic vim stuff the
basic vim key bindings the basic vim
functions and settings and commands and
all that and you don't bother using some
plugins because those themselves have
different commands and different key
bindings and different settings and so
on so focus on the basics and once you
have the basics down you can you can
install some plugins you can you can
customize your setup
now in order to do this what we need to
do first here or what is recommended to
do first here is to install neovim
instead of vim neovim is just better
faster and it supports more plugins that
vim does not support so if you want to
have
a better experience and you still want
to keep using vim in the terminal i
recommend you use neovim and for that we
type sudo app install neovim on linux i
have this installed already
and in my case if i now type neovim it
opens a neovim full of plugins you can
see here in a second it opens dashboard
it opens a couple of things your new vim
when you install it will look probably
like the basic bim
uh just it's going to say neovem instead
of them
so in order to install plugins what you
need to do is you need to go to the
browser you need to go to google and you
need to type vimpluck or you can just go
to the link here getup.com
june gun slash vim dash plug and then
you can
read the instructions here all you need
to do once you have neovem installed is
you copy this here on unix and linux so
also on windows if you're using the
windows subsystem for linux you're
copying that pasting it running it and
that's it then you have vim plug
installed basically um and one thing
that you need to know is that the neovim
config is not a vimrc file so it's not
using the same config as uh the basic
vim installation the neoven config is
located in
the user directory slash dot config
and uh then here i think it was
was it neovim or was it nvim i think it
was nvm right
there you go and here we have a file
called or usually you don't have a file
you need to create one called init.vim
so
cat init.bim this is my file this is the
content of my file here
so usually you don't have the nvm
directory and you also don't have the
init.bim file so you create it
you create both of them you create a
directory and you create the init.vim
file and this is actually what is going
to be used now you can see that my file
here is quite comprehensive you don't
need to understand anything that's
written here this is my config but the
basic structure is quite simple
so first of all what you see up here
is the commands we already talked about
you know tab stop smart tab auto and
then no we didn't talk about smart tab
whatever number relative number all that
then down here you can see a bunch of
settings that you don't need to
understand the they are plug-in specific
for example here i have a plug-in called
vim tags it has some certain uh
parameters or settings that i want to
pass here uh i have set certain icons up
here all details that don't matter to
you right now what you need to
understand is that there is this section
here once you have vim plug installed
what you can do is you can type call
plug hashtag begin
and then
call plug hashtag end and in between now
this is actually
not on the right place here so ignore
that um but in between those two
commands we install the plugins by
typing plug and then the link to the
github repository that's literally all
we need to do in order to install
or to actually to to say that we want to
install them plugins in order to
actually install them we need to type
colon plug install like that colon plug
install and then it's going to open up
on the left here the plug installation
in my case it says already installed
already installed already installed
um
and all these things here all these
plugins are just github repositories vim
surround is a github repository nerd
tree which is the thing you see on the
left here this is nurturing just a a a
getup repository so all you need to do
is you need to go to the repository
which is even plugin you copy the link
you type plug there you go and then so
you have the section called plug begin
call plug end in between plug
and the link and then essentially you go
in and you say plug install and it
installs the plugin then maybe
you have to rerun and then the plugins
are activated and what you do with the
individual plugins so which color
schemes you choose what settings the
plugins have i cannot make a tutorial on
that because each plugin is
unique so nurturing has certain things
to set up vim commentary has different
things to set up but all these plugins
have functionalities for example with
vim commentary i can just go to a couple
of lines i can mark them and i can type
gc to comment them out and this is
across multiple different programming
languages so this is not a default vim
key binding this is an advanced thing
that's that is introduced with vim
commentary them airlines which you see
down here so i don't want to talk too
much about specific plugins here those
are my plugins and i also have on my
github repository i can show you that
for those of you who are interested on
my github i have so on getup.com
neural nine i have my config files for
those of you who want to have my
installation but keep in mind that
so you go to config files you go to init
vim keep in mind this is a pretty
advanced setup oh this is actually an
outdated version so maybe pick this one
it's it's a little bit more lightweight
but you're going to have to go through
some installation steps maybe you have
to install node maybe you have to
install a language server and all that
but those are the plugins i use you can
just go online type
top ten vim plugins to install
install those and that's it and the good
thing is that this is not one ide or one
editor that you download like vs code
and then you install some plugins this
is your thing this is how you design it
so
with those plugins in my settings i have
a unique setup that no one else has
unless of course they copy my config but
you can have your setup the way you want
it and this is very awesome this is how
you can set up neovim to be
actually something approximating an ide
now using vim or neovim as your actual
editor is fine but oftentimes you're
going to make use of pytron you're going
to use intellij you're going to use
rstudio you're going to use a jupiter
notebook you're going to use uh overleaf
and so on and most tools out there since
vim is really an awesome tool and a lot
of people like it support vim bindings
either natively or through a plugin so
for example in pycharm here for python
development you can go to file to
settings
and you can go to plugins and you can
download the ideavim plugin you can
install the idea then plugin and once
you have that in pycharm you can use vim
key bindings now of course you cannot
install 1000 plugins here because this
is pycharm this is not vim you cannot
install nur tree and all that but you
can use the vim binding so i'm here in
pycharm and i can say for example change
inner parentheses there you go
undo with you
um i can use visual mode here i can
press c in order to change and all that
so all these things work here all the
basic key bindings work also in pycharm
also in overleaf also in rstudio and
jupyter notebook all that and for the
intellij products or for the jetbrains
products so intellij pycharm and so on
uh you also have
an actual vimrc file which is called
idea rc so you go
to your users directory and then you go
to ideavimrc
and they offer actually two plugins so
they offer
surround and commentary surrounding
commentary are actually vim plugins and
you cannot use plug install here so you
cannot use vim plug in pycharm but you
can use surround and commentary so
commentary is basically what i told you
you select a couple of lines and you
type gc and it comments them out or you
just go to a single line just type gcc
to comment the line out this works also
in pycharm by setting uh setting the
commentary and surround is basically
surrounding a word so for example if i
pick this one here i think it was y s w
or actually y s inner w
quotation marks like that this is
basically for surrounding not too
important
but this is what i do on on a regular
basis i use neovim sometimes if i just
edit some some small scripts or
something but if i use an ide if i use
pycharm if i use intellij whatever i do
unless maybe microsoft office so unless
unless i i do some word stuff i always
use use them bindings everywhere and
this speeds up your code so you don't
have to use vim even if you don't like
the terminal even if you don't want to
use them in a terminal i recommend
starting to use vim bindings in your
other ides including visual studio code
so that's it for this vim course i hope
you enjoyed it and hope you learned
something if so let us know by hitting
the like button and leaving a comment in
the comment section down below besides
that don't forget to subscribe to free
code camp and maybe you're also
interested in checking out my channel
neural nine i make a lot of videos on
data science machine learning python and
so on so if you're interested take a
look and besides that thank you for
watching see you and bye